foreign
is a managed service there are many
configurations exposed to you as a user
if the configurations are not done
properly it can lead to failures during
cluster Creation in this video you will
learn how to troubleshoot such failures
in datapark
the most common issues in creating
datapark clusters are networking
problems missing IAM permissions inquiry
data perk and Hadoop properties and
failures and custom initialization
actions
troubleshooting a cluster creation error
might seem overwhelming at first but
there are many tools available in Google
Cloud platform to help you here are the
most handy ones Cloud logging gathers
logs from all Google Cloud components
and has lots of filters for quickly
finding what you're looking for cloud
monitoring collects metrics from cluster
components like information about memory
CPU networking and jobs a diagnostic
turbo is a snapshot of logs and
configurations from a cluster it is
useful for the cloud support team to
perform Advanced investigations in this
episode I will walk you through how to
use each of these tools to troubleshoot
a live data per cluster creation issue
let's get started go to the datapark
Clusters page in Google Cloud console
click on create cluster customize the
cluster according to your needs and
click create
oops cluster creation failed
to investigate this issue I'll start
with Cloud logging by going to logs
Explorer page
select the time interval that includes
the cluster creation failure and click
apply I'll keep it as the last hour
in the left hand side pane set the
resource type to cloud data per cluster
ensure the severity is set to error you
can narrow down the search by filtering
based on the cluster's name or tuid in
case there are multiple clusters by the
same name so let's take a look
aha there indicates that one of the
service accounts involved is missing the
compute subnetwork's use permission for
the shared VPC used by the cluster this
is important because dataproc needs the
permission to create VMS in the shared
VPC if you are not sure about the error
then search the public tags for the
error or the permission which should
help you address the issue
according to the docs the network user
role should be assigned to the datapart
service agent in the shared vpc's host
project in order for this to work
go to IAM and admin IAM page click Grant
access fill out the principal's email
address
and select the intended role click save
and wait for a few minutes so the
permissions can propagate
let's try creating the cluster again
hmm the cluster still seems to be
failing after a while
let's check out Cloud logging again
good news is that the error about IAM
permissions is gone but now we're
getting this new timer when the cluster
knows try to talk to each other this
sounds like a networking problem
reviewing their message carefully hints
at possible firewall issues
since firewall misconfiguration is the
most common type of network issue in the
cloud I'm going to check for packets
dropped by the firewall in Cloud
monitoring navigate to metrics Explorer
from the search bar or the navigation
menu at the left select the correct time
frame from the top right corner I will
keep it as the last hour on the resource
and metrics in the left pane search for
firewall
review the metrics description to make
sure it is relevant
click apply
from the left hand menu you may filter
the VM instances based on their cluster
click add filter set the label to data
per cluster name or uuid add your target
cluster's name or uuid in the value
field and click done
and that proves it there are quite a lot
of packets being denied by the firewall
in this network
to fix this issue I'd add a rule for
allowing traffic between all cluster
nodes in the shared vpc's host project
remember it will take a few minutes for
the new rules to propagate
let's try creating the cluster once more
great it's working now
if the information from cloud logging
and Cloud monitoring is not sufficient
for you to diagnose your issue then you
can create a diagnostic turbo using the
diagnose command
use this command to create the turbo for
your data per cluster this saves the
turbo to your cluster's cloud storage
bucket
follow the instructions in the commands
output to allow Cloud support access to
the file
remember to share the turbos address
with Google Cloud support as part of
your support case
for more information about Cloud logging
Cloud monitoring and the diagnostic
command check out these documentations
foreign
[Music]